[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تصفيه تقييم الاسواق انطلقت ثلاثه مشتركين
يتنافسون اليوم للوصول الى المربع النهائي
لجنه التحكيم تبحث عن الافضل الدكتور عبد
الحميد الزهيري الدكتور خالد العالي
البروفيسور فؤاد مرعب
ورحله نجوم العلوم لا تكتمل من دون
خالد الجميلي
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته اهلا بكم
في مرحله تقييم الاسواق من الموسم التاسع
نجوم العلوم المنتجات جاهزه تصميم وهندسه
واثبات الفكره مرحله قطعها 6 مشتركين في
الحلقات السابقه
اذن حسم لمشعل و وسيم و محمد الجفيري
تنطلق الان ثلاثه جاهزين والكل يبقى
الوصول الى المربع النهائي قبل البدء
بالتصفيات نظره سريعه على بعض من مسيره
واستعداد المشاركين لمواجهات اليوم
[موسيقى]
شهدت مرحله بناء النموذج تصفيات حاسمه
ومباشره المحدده
ولازالت والاشياء النفطيه ولا شي
تكنولوجيا من اجهاز كبير جدا في الاخر انا
برايي
قادره على اثرها مخترعون الثلاثه مع
ابتكارات جاهزه
لمرحله تقييم الاسواق ومن سيغادر النهائيه
اول المغادرين وسام معروضه الدله للقهوه
العربيه
[موسيقى]
البرنامج كل شيء
بقى سته في مهب مرحله تقييم الاسواق
انقسموا فيها الى فريقين الواحد
[موسيقى]
انا احمد فرج بنفس لعلنا
ستكون وبين وسيم والموزعه القريب وجبات
المرضى اشهر لهلا
عاملا ثمانيه ايام ومشعل مع سوار الملاحه
للدجاج انا حاليا جاهز ان شاء الله الى ان
ومحمد ور بوتو تعليم الاطفال الصوم اللي
تعلمتها في استشراف الشعور قريب جدا اللي
تعلمتها في كلها
مهندسون الثلاثه يدخلون عالم الاعمال
حياتهم وحياه الاخرين في وايد ناس انتظر
منكم مرحلتهم توالت فيها اللقاءات بعدما
الخامس حسيت انه انا لازم يثبت حاله قدام
العالم من الشخصيات اللي انا معجب فيها
وانا كنت محله او اي شخص حيث حتى نفسيا
ممكن الفكره حتموتوا كما يخرج من ولكن
احنا شفنا العكس طيب بوش
العلوم وصلتنا للمرحله اللي نحنا لازم
نكمل معنا
ولم يبقى مجال الا
[موسيقى]
معنا اليوم كل هذه الكلمات
على مستوى عالمي
[موسيقى]
المشترك
[تصفيق]
جاء الهجوم العلوم حاملا واستاذه نوع من
ذكيه وغادرنا وفي نفسه حلم الابداع لمين
ما بل تالق في ابتكار خوارزميه ضعيف السمع
دخلت الاسواق العالميه ضيفنا اليوم خريج
نجوم العلوم النور
في وطننا العربي من اكبر المخاوف تواجه
الشباب يتعثر لتحقيق الاهداف
بس انا شخصيا التعثر هو يا اللي وصلنا
لهدفين
انها تكون بالمركز الخامس ما تقدر
النهائيات شعور لغايه حظ اوفر لي انور من
سوريا
الحقيقه بعد هجوم العلوم مختلفه تماما
كانت رحلتي مليئه بالعقبات الحواجز
ولكن هلا بعد خمس سنين حياتي انقلبت راسا
على عقب اساس شركتين بريطانيا والدنمارك
وكملت على نفس المشروع اللي تكتب البرنامج
واللي هو
وحصلت على مجموعه استثمارات فوق ال مليون
دولار حققنا المرتبه الاولى بمسابقات بعده
بلدان العالم مثل امريكا وبريطانيا والدول
وانا اليوم كشخص ما قدر يوصل على
النهائيات صار عنده خبره كافيه بمساعده
جيل جديد يقدر يوسف
الاثنين شكرا انا حقيقه العلوم بيتك في
هذا البيت ان تسعى النوم عبر الاستاذه
الذكيه اليوم انت اكثر الناس استقبال
ماشاء الله تبارك الرحمان عن طريق جهاز
خوارزميه السمع لضعاف البصر حدثني عن
الفكره هذه من النوم الى الاستحقاق نحنا
بعد ما راح تجي العلوم كانت انه يكون
عندنا سمارت فون يقدر يلعب في الاصوات
ويساعد الناس اللي عندهم مشاكل سماء
فالحمد الله من خلالها الخوارزميه اه ضمنا
ساعدنا س سمو انفسنا حياه كثيره عليهم
والحمد لله ان تشرك العالميين
وبعد نجوم العلوم الموسم الخامس فيه الى
اليوم كيف تشوف الحياه في عالم الابداع
وعلى ال ال اه رياضه العمال خلينا نقول
نجوم العلوم بعدها ال خمس سنين يعني
جدا كانت مختلفه بيقول العلوم الدلال
في حاله ما حدا ما حدا يساعده بدك تعتمد
على حاله تماما وتسعى ان كانت تلاقي
فلسطيني حتى تطلع
يعني خلاص تقدر تبني حياتك ومستقبلك
اذن مرحله صعبه ووعد فيها كثيرا حتى تقدر
توصل لمرحله الحمد لله بقدر اقول فيه انا
انسان مستقره عندي شركتين صار فيه عندنا
ما بيعرفوا في عنا استثمار في العالم ال
الك استاذ الحمد لله حول العالم
وكذلك كلمتين او قيمتين اساسيتين توجه لهم
المشتركين
السلام حتى لو ما كانت نفور من نجوم
العلوم فيه كثير على استمرار اليوم في
مواجهات لجنه التحكيم اليوم قلب يعني
بسرعه
يعني
شريط الذكريات واتباعا من خمس سنين هلا عم
ينعاد عم نتذكر وين كنتوا كنت قاعد
يعني الله يكون بالعون بس انا متاكد كلن
عملوا شيء نحو عن جد يعني بصراحه حتى لو
انه فيه اثنين اللي ما الاخير انا متاكد
مستقبلهم كثير واحد انا متحمس لمعرفه من
اول اثنين راح يبين تكون الى المرحله
النهائيه وان شاء الله كل التوفيق نعود ان
شاء الله معك
ابداع لا تنتهي داخل المختبر نجوم العلوم
هي بدايه نجاحات متواصله ثلاثه اذا يريدون
الان التاهل وامامهم مواجهات ان وحده مع
المستهلك والثانيه مع لجنه التحكيم
التفاصيل بعد الفاصل معانا عبر موقع
البرنامج
وصفحات التواصل الاجتماعي فيس بوك
فاصل قصير وبنرجع
[موسيقى]
نعم
حياكم الله مش على فكره جهازا يساعد على
التنقل في رحاب الاماكن المقدسه لكنه يبدو
انه سيستخدم الصور ليقوده الى بر الامان
وسط عصير الاسئله والمواجهات الصعبه زوار
الملاحظ الحجاج مع مشعل من السعوديه
اركان الاسلامي خمسه والحجر كنا منها لمن
استطاع اليه سبيلا تشير الاحصائيات وزاره
الحج بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه ان اربعه
وثمانين بالمائه من الحجاج يخشون الضياع
وان هذا ما ينقص مرحله حجهم ويهدد سلامتهم
لهذا السبب تذكرنا الجدار
هو الزوار الوحيد من نوعه في العالم الذي
يدل ويتيح للحاج التنقل داخل وخارج مباني
المشاعر المقدسه بدقه وامانه ما يميز قال
ان بطاريته تعمل لفتره تفوق فتره موسم
الحج وتتيح للحاج والمعتمر
امكانيه تخزين وحفظ بياناتهم الشخصيه
وتمكين الجهات المختصه من معرفه اماكن
تواجدها عرفنا ان تعمل دال بمجرد ضغطه زر
واحده وترصد الحاج بس هما يصيب الهدف
سوف يخدم مليار ونصف مليار مسلم لتاجيج
مناسك الحج بسهوله وامان دعنا الان نشاهد
التقرير الخبراء ومعرفه النتيجه
الله
وحكم تواجده مع الحجاج والمعتمرين عرفت
كان في حاجه
الاسوار الداعي
خصيصا لتنشيط جميع الحجاج والمعتمرين على
اماكن وجودهم وتسهل عليهم مناسك الحج
انا متاكد من الخبره اللي اكتسبها من
السنه راح اوصل لجميع المستهلكين
[موسيقى]
اتوقع اللي يكون المتواجدين في ناس لهم
خبره
اهلا وسهلا السلام
احنا انا خدمت الحجاج كم تطور الكشافه
لمده اكثر من ثلاث سنين كنت اشوفه المشاكل
اللي والحجاج والمعتمرين في زعمه الحجاج
الخيم كلها متشابهه كان حتى بعض الحجاج
وصلوا عندهم قلق انه يمكن الشخص هذا او
الاختراع لا شك انه اذا جزء من الاهداف
المرسومه له يسهم الحجاج اداء المناسك
بتوجههم الى اماكن التي يتوجهون الى
انا في امام مسجد التابع لوزاره الاوقاف
واخر مرحله الماجستير في جامعه حمد بن
خليفه في تخصص المعاصر
الصعوبات التي تواجه الجيش خلال الحج
متنوعه فاذا كان عدد الحجاج كبيره كما هو
الحال في زماننا هذا هذا لا شك يؤدي الى
صعوبه على اداء هذه الاباده كما شرعت بين
الجهاز هذا الخدمه اللي
الصوت
البطاريه البطاريه تدوم اكثر من موسم الحج
يعني مثلا تدوم اكثر من خمسين عجبتني
الفكره ببساطه فعالياتها اتوقع انه ممكن
تحل مشاكل كبيره في الحج
الرسمي من جامعه جورجتاون في قطر وكان فيه
فرصه انه الطلاب من الجامعات كلها يطلعوا
على رحله عمر شفنا المخيم اللي بيقعد فيها
المقيمين للحج واعدادها كل الخيام بشكلها
طبعا الواحد مرات الاخبار بسهوله وممكن ان
حصلت فرق ما بين العوائل اكثر اشيء بيكون
عندنا يعني فيه شويه مشاكل هو توجيه
المستخدم كيفيه استعمال الجهاز
كل هذا الموضوع
انا بقدر الامكان ان هناك جميع الاعمار
يستخدمها مواجه مثلا كبار فلسطيني ممكن ما
بيقدر يستخدمها ولكن وجود الكشاف بدل ما
ان فتح الخريطه اخطار المكان اللي هو مسجل
فيه
يعني امشي على السامه اتوقع اليوم ما كانت
نتيجه حلو اه كريم وستين بالمنتج اللي انا
فيها ان شاء الله سعاده الرضى اللي حتى
اليوم في وجههم تكون ان شاء الله معكوسه
في النتائج اللي اليوم بالنسبه لكم اشتروا
الجهاز انا افضل ان كل الحديث
حاليا انا منسق انها من المسلمين العمراني
والعماره المجتمعات الاسلاميه بخصوص مدينه
مكه او مدينه المناوره يحتاج الى جهود
كبير جدا ان احنا نعرف نوفر البيئه
العمرانيه الانسب لاستقبال اعداد كبيره من
المسلمين في مناسك الحج
الاستفاده المملكه تستفيد من المعلومات
اللي ها يتم اكتسابها
كل الحديث وقت واحد لا حسن دراسه ميدانيه
بيوفر
الحركه الاداره افضل فطبعا مش مساله شخصيه
لا تشتري جهاز اولا هم اللي وفروا انا في
رايي الشخصي لو السعر المناسب احنا
المنظمه تم اصدار الجهاز
واحده مناسبه جدا
احنا بنقول الخدمات اللي راغب الحج او
العمره بدايه من الى استخراج التاشيره
لحجز الفنادق الطيران
نفسه الله حامل الجهاز بيخلي للعباده الحب
القيم المشروع الاربعه نواحي مختلفه صراحه
انا عاليه احنا بنتكلم على مشروع فيه
امكانيه انه يفضل يتطور ان اقيمت متوسط
نظرا لتفاعل معها والاستقبالات منها اكثر
في جيل الشباب الجيل الذي تجاوز الخمسين
المشاركين فكره
اختراع كويس بس كانوا منقسمين فائده
الاختراق
الحين احنا في مرحله تقييم الاسواق تقول
لي بوضوح قال في سوره الدال تنباع حل فيه
من الخبراء قالوا
الحكومه هي اللي توفر هذه توضح لنا شوي
الباب الاول طبعا هو معاملتي مع الجهات
المختصه اللي هي الحكومه العربيه الامه
العربيه السعوديه
فيه تعاون من الطرفين ويكون فيه كامل
المشروع طبعا هذا حيكون وين وين من
الجهتين للحكومه نفسها وكمان للحجاج
والمعتمرين
الاخر ممكن اكون اتعامل مع حملات الحج
نفسهم الحاج نفسه اذا كانت موجوده في
البيت تبع الحجاج حتكون
اتكلمنا لون السياره يكون مناسب انه يتحقق
الهدايا
ممكن
مناسبه ممكن
المتحده الى عجز جهازي الحج يكون قيمه مش
وليله والقيمه كبيره اللي كثير كبيره فاذا
كان القيمه اللي للجهاز مناسبه في تقديم
وان بعد التاكد اللي بيعمل بصوره سليمه
بتخيل سعر ال اه
انا بدي احرص قدر الامكان انه ان شاء الله
ما تتعدى اكثر من خمسين دولار هذا اذا كان
فيه ناس اللي كان فيه ما راح يكون الاستاذ
كثيرا قال طبعا ان تكون اقل من خمسين
دولار لان اغلبيه الحجاج ممكن يكون من ال
اه العالم الثالث مثلا ما نبغي نزيد الحمل
عليهم هي دعوه مش كمان الربحيه بالزياده
الدعوه خدمه اخواننا المسلمين والمعتمرين
في مكان والله وخمسين دولار مبلغ يتفاوت
من من مكان الثاني اعتقد ان في دول الخليج
مش مبلغ كبير ولكن حيكون في دول ثانيه
يكون مبلغ
اللجنه لازم اللي بتمثل السوق كله لا لا
صحيح طلع فيه عندك كبيره فيه
اكثريه عرفت كثير مهم جدا يعني مقابله مع
ام كانت يعني الشرف يعني تعلمت منهم
الكثير وكان الان
الجماعه نحترمهم كثير انا اعطيك علامات
على اربعه معايير
درجه الابتكار دراسه الاثر ليش هي مفيده
وجماليه بيت هذا المنتج برايك من بين هودي
الاربعاء الا بوجود وقال لي شوي على
العالم يعطوا فيها
العالمي تاثير في المجتمع
تاثير ممكن يكون تاثير سلبي لا يعني انشاء
الله
انشاء الله
شكرا
مرتاح اه
اجابات الصحفي مكان الصحه لكن في جدا لولا
كان فيه نقاش كثير صعب حسيت وكان كثير
رايي وهو عم يعطي الاشتراك
[موسيقى]
لكل مشترك مجموعه تقييم متخصصه في هذه
التصفيات التصويت راح يكون على مرحلتين
الاولى تصويت مجموعه التقييم ويشكل خمسين
في المائه من العلامه النهائيه والمرحله
الثانيه تصويت اجل التحكيم في نهايه
المواجهات ويشكل خمسين في المائه من
العلامه النهائيه مشعل قال ما لديه تصويت
اعضاء مجموعات التقييم يبدا
[موسيقى]
يبدا متوترا ويريد معرفه النقاط التي حصل
عليها من مجموعه التقييم
نتيجه اصبحت جاهزه مشعل حصل على
واحد واربعين فاصله سته من فلسطين
مبروك النتيجه النهائيه والتي هي طبعا
الخمسين البيئه الثانيه من لجنه تحكيم راح
تكون ان شاء الله في نهايه هذه الحلقه انا
خلصت من مقابلات مع الحكام ولكن فيه خوف
من وسيم ومن محمد دشتي اعتبارها عاليه
حاليا ولكن لازم اعرف الدرجات المشتركين
المسلم محمد علشان نتاكد انه انا في بر
الامان او من ثوار التنقل عبر تقنيه
بلوتوث الى التنقل المرئي بين غرف
المستشفيات ومع عامل بري الى سيوزع وسيم
حجه العلميه على طبق من ذهب لاقناع لجنه
التحكيم ومجموعه تقييم جديده متخصصه
الموزع الالي لوجهات المرضى مع وسيله
لما نكون بما كان مثل المستشفى لما نكون
عادلين نعم الفريق باستخدام التكنولوجيا
هوني بلش اكثر من اربعه الاف وخمسمائه
واجب العام يتوزع و او اسبوعين المستشفى
حجم هذه العمليه عم تستهلك ناش بالمائه من
وقت فريق الخدمه الطبيه بمعدل اربع ساعات
يوميا
الفريق المفهوم الجديد لا يغير رعايه صحيه
اسابيع على تحسين تحميل وتوزيع واجبات
نختلف بريطانيه
المريض الصحيحه
وثمانين والسلامه وبدون اي تغيير البنى
التحتيه لمستشفي
اساسات امير يعني افضل المريض والحفاظ على
خصوصيته ويمنع الخطا البشري بالتوزيع راح
يؤثر كثير من المال والوقت ما عم بيصير
مصلحه الرعايه الصحيه وهيدا اكيد من حق كل
مريض خلينا نكون ايد واحده وان خلال هذه
التكنولوجيا على مستشفياتنا منهم من قطر
لكن للعبد نتيجه مسيره طويله من الوقود
المانيا واخيرا
بس لدى المستهلكين هو خلونا نشوف كيف صارت
ك ارى في هذا التقرير
مرحله البزنس ولا يجتمع الابتكار مع
التسويه
هاي المرحله كل ها بتعتمد على الاسلوب على
تحفيز الساعه للمستهلكين
لدى المستهلكين بابتكار ساسه واهميته
لخدمه المجتمع هو طريق للنجاح
اعتقد راح واجه اشخاص بالفيديو عم يعرفوا
لا يخدم الرعايه الصحيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مهم عندي
انا
مسؤول عن
التكنولوجيا اللي احتياجات
نقل الاغراض
ولكن عمليات التفريق عمليه التحميل تتم عن
طريق الموظفين
الفكره بنفس الوقت
[موسيقى]
يعني مثلها
ممكن في القطاعات
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تقرير انه
معدل عندك هون الفرصه ترفع
مستوى الثقه والعلامات تبعك بلش معك بشان
هيك بالنسبه للغه والاسم
انه لا انسان عادي مثلا بالشرق الاوسط او
باوروبا بتقول لك وين عايشه بالكويت اذا
بيقول هايدا شو اول شيء بيجي على راسه
انا كنت حابب يروح
شغله كثير جدا يا اللي هي شفتها انت بتقول
في عندك تماما وفي عندك اذا انا بدي لخص
كل التقرير اللي قدرنا هون وال وال
والنقاش اللي بينكم ان الخلاف بالتقرير في
عندك فرصه توضح بسرعه اكيد ما عم تقول انه
انا ما بدي الى
تعمل انت ما يعني
تمثل هون
لا يمكن ان
يكون مع المريض لانه يمكن في انه هو بيكون
شو لا فرق بين معامله احمد او
المشروع
اللي هو شريك معي انا
على الفور عنده عنده
بيقول انه هي مسؤوله
عن موارد بشريه والموارد البشريه
هايدي الشخصيه من شخص واحد لانه بدو يهتم
ويمكن يكون على حساب
الصحيه البشريه الانسانيه ضروري ولكن
اقول انه
عليها
مش معقول يعني انه
[ضحك]
انه في بعض
انه موجود موجود
لكن ما
المواجهه مع
يعني انا ما عرفت انه يطلع منها الكثير في
ضغط
انه هذا
قد يكون تكلفته
انت يعني
بالنسبه
انه
الحريري
موجود
سته وثلاثين الف دولار
نعم
طبعا مش متحمس انت يعني
على كلام
وبناءا على اللي انا شفتها
ممتاز حاليا
فاين اللي منشوفها طبعا فيه كلام ثاني
يعني مثل ما قال لك الحين واثنين في
البروتوتايب مستخدم مش الفرقه
طبعا لازم نسوي دراسه
الخبراء اوضح انه
انه اه اه احنا نعم
[موسيقى]
نعم لتقييم المريض
الاشياء اللي وصلناها بحيث انه يكون في
دوره كامله يعني
متحكمه بحيث انه يكون
يعني
والموظفين
صحيح لانه هو ما فيه هناك خطا
صحيح
كمان هناك وقت كثير
بتصير المريض
بيفتحوا حريص شو شو شو بتقول لك
بينما طالب يكون انسان جاي عم كل الصواني
الله يرضى عليك هذا الص خليه واقف على
اليمين خلاص كله فاضي كل ثواني على المجلس
الموقف لما اجي المراد
يحكى عن لانه بمحل من المحلات دكتور صغيره
عندما كان عم ابدا باي
اه انا مش ابدا ان تعمل اوتوميشن بس بال
توزيع لانه اكيد عامل الخطا الانساني في
توزيع الوجبات
عليه ادى عمل الخطا في توزيع الوجبات
المستشفى
لما مريض فيها
طبيعي يعني
شيء يؤثر عليه
في اول مره
الوقت راح توصل الوقت المناسب وانا
الوقت المناسب
وتخلي فؤاد
من اول ما قبلت ان البرنامج
هذا الشخص يعني ما في شيء لح وقف اللي
عنده كل شيء كل شيء موجود عندهم حتى الان
كانوا مستعدين
نرى انها انه انه هاي بدايه الطريق
في الامر ان لمجموعه التقييم وجمال ساحه
لن يؤثر في معايير التصويت العلميه الان
القرار المجموعه
[موسيقى]
الله
وسيم ينتظر النتيجه بفارغ الصبر والحصول
على علامه عاليه فرصه ذهبيه للوصول الى
النهائي نتيجه جاهزه تقسيم حصل من خمسين
على سبعه وثلاثين فاصله خمسه
اذن النتيجه النهائيه ان شاء الله بعد جمع
الاصوات لجنه التحكيم في التقييم العام
ستكون في نهايه هذه الحلقه تلاحظ عليه انه
يتوقع صراحه اه بعتقد بعتقد مشروع اه يعني
بيستاهل انهم بالفين
وبعد ان اكيد عندي امل انه يكون
مواجهه الليله لم تنتهي بعد وبقي متنافسه
خير الوصول الى نهائي نجوم العلوم فاصل في
فتره في معاني عبر موقع البرنامج ستكون
وصفحات التواصل الاجتماعي فيس بوك
[موسيقى]
اكثر من عشره ملايين طفل العربي راح
يستفيدوا من ابتكار ان شاء الله في التاهل
مرتبط في الحقائق العلميه و باقناع لجنه
التحكيم ومجموعه التقييم التعليم العالي
تفاعلي للاطفال الصمت مع محمد الجفيري من
قطر
في ملتقى العلماء من
في قطر فاونديشن نطلب الى العالم اليوم
منصه تعليميه وهي المنصه التعليميه الاولى
في العالم مبروك
مبروك الان سيده يتكلم مع الاطفال بلغه
الاشاره يحكي قصصا لهم
يلعب معهم ويعلمهم ادعوكم الان لمشاهده
التقرير الذي اعده مجموعه من الخبراء في
هذه الرحله
سيد وراح يكون ثوره في عالم السمو بيعرف
السن ان شاء الله راح يغير حياه الكثير من
نجاح الحقيقي راح يكون لما اشوف سيد وعند
كل طفل عنده اعاقه سمعيه في هذا العالم
الفكره اليوم
[موسيقى]
الاطفال ويحاول لغه الاشاره وغير ايضا
عندنا ان تسوى الحرف هذا سويت الحرب راح
يعمل تحرك هذا انت عملتها صحه قاعده تتطور
الافكار شويه شويه وبعد ان تملك على بدايه
السلم الامور ان شاء الله
كلهم ولا ثلاثه
والله شوف ان اللجنه يمكن تم والله
نحنا بتدريب طبعا الاول عن الاختراع
وفائدته انا في مجال للاعاقه السمعيه
تقريبا واحد وعشرين سنه قريه شارع الصغير
انا ب مجمع التربيه السمعيه الهدف
التعليمي بحث للطلاب من حيث مناهج من حيث
ال التواصل وطبعا هذا كله يتم عن طريق لغه
الاشاره بالنسبه له بالصمت تعلمت معلومات
مثل ايش المثال احنا المشاكل الكثيره اللي
بتواجهنا انه ما في برامج التدخل المبكر
احنا بتفاجا في طلاب يدفعوا عندنا على
المدرسه وما تلقى اي مهارات او اي تدخل
مبكر بالتالي هذا بيسوى عندنا تحد كبير
جدا الشيء اللي انا ما بقدر اعطي في قواعد
للتعاون مع لغه الاشاره يعني نتكلم عن
ايماءات الجلسه الان الوجه عن حركه الجسم
بتوفير خبراء تكنولوجيا ممكن تطور الفتره
الاكبر من الوضع اللي هي موجوده كثيره ان
ا وجودي هون انا والدي والتي من الاشخاص
انا افضل السبل الرياضيه في المائه وسبعين
خبير الاشاره في المجمعه الاسره اغلب
افرادها من صوت لي شوي بالبدايه مشكله
تعلم اللغه
في صعوبه في تعلم اللغه المنطقه ككل اما
تعلم لغه الاشاره اذا ما كان فيه رعايه
وما كان في المتابع من البدايه يمكن حسم
مشاكل نفسيه للمستقبل كون انه بدايه اول
خمس سنوات في بدايه تعلم لها تفاعليا
الروبوت لازم يكون في ايمان الاصل لما
يطلع يشوف الفيس طفل لا ياخذ فقط كاداه
كاداه حركه ليس الا لكنك مشاعرك حسين ينقص
هذا الشيء وهذا اللي لازم يكون متوفر ممكن
مختلف تماما وهو الاطفال دائما
الاشياء المتحركه
بدايه الشغل في المساعده من حوالي اربعطاش
سنه استخدام الاجهزه استفهام ومع الاطفال
يعني تفاؤل مع الاجهزه اثبت فعاليته في
التوحد ممكن يسبب فعاليته بنفس الطريقه في
العلاقات الثنائيه لم يكون الربط في غرفه
نفسها مع الطفل وهو بيلعب معه انه يقول
انه هو خليل بين اللعب والتعلم يعني انه
الاب والمدرسه يتحكموا في المحتويات
الجهاز
يعني
[موسيقى]
التحديات اللي هي في حركه الاصابع
اذا استطاع انه يتغلب عليها
الابتكار فيها لانه لغه الاشارات العربي
الانجليزي رؤيه هذا مش موجه للعرب بل هو
منطلق من العرب العالم
ابتكار لانه ما فيه للاشارات اللغه
العربيه الاشارات العربيه
الانجليزي مش بس اللغه العربيه انا ما
ذكرت اللغه العربيه
التصويت
للاطفال العرب المقدمه كان مش بس للعرب
هذا الاختراع لجميع الصنف العالم هذا
الاختراع راح يعمل ثوره نوعيه في لغه
الاشاره في جميع العالم راح يستخدم العربي
الصيني الياباني اي انسان العربي او الله
بتقولوا انت
الحرب اكيد
المعلم في معنى واحد سوريا الاسبوع
رحلتها يكون خير خلف لخير سلف
يزيدوا انا بالنسبه لي انا عم اقول لك سيد
مع قبل يعني انا عندي معنا باللجنه
انه هايدي
يعني
انا عندي
حبيت اخذ رايكم
المقترحه
يحضرون باب الحاره
محمد يعني اول ما ف اه يعني فعلا انه جدا
يسترخي
من حاله بشكل كثير اوي هذه المرحله نقول
صعبه
المسار اللي يمشي في المختاره
لما يوصل الى فتره السوق ويخبط السوق يصير
فيه احباط لان المساله في نهايه المطاف
قيمه الاقتراع بالنسبه للسوق ان اوجه
السؤال للخبراء تشترونه واذا تشترون
طبعا انا بالنسبه لي شيء
طبيعي بيشتغل
ما هو قضيه الدفع مرهون في شيء يعني انه
الان الخلاصه او الافضل التشكيل المدرسي
ولا للبيت
للجميع
طيب اذا كان
تقول انه
اللغه العربيه صحيح
العالم
يعني
اذا غامرت في شرف مروم
محمد
يعني بدايه استفتاحيه
كانت بالنسبه
يعني انا عارف انه العالم المشروع
[موسيقى]
الطموح انظر للسماء لكن يكون
هذا الواقع
يعني هذه الثقه احيانا تكون خطره لانه فيه
درجه بينها وبين
انا كنت واثق من نفسه تواصل درجه الثقه
توصل العالم
ان شاء الله باذن الله
ويشارك ويترجم باذن الله للمشاركين باذن
الله انا ما اقول يعني على الاقل في
اللغه العربيه
في ناحيه ثانيه يفوت لهون كانت انه
مع انه اقولها بصعوبه يعني انه
دكتور ما
في تجارب صعب انه سيدي يعني
الناحيتين في جانب انه
فعال في التعليم انه نوصل للتعليم مفيد
اكثر والجيش مسلح التعليم فعال ومسلم
لانه
المراد كيف شفت من ناحيتين الناحيه الاولى
فعال وفعال جدا ليش لان عندك عدد من
المعلمين يمكن يكون معين جديد في المدرسه
واصبحت الاشاره يحتاج
حتى يعلم اللي بيستفيد هو اشاره علما ان
تطالب الاصل او وياخذ منه هو كمان نفس
الاشاره حتى
الانتراكشن الموجوده عليه موجوده مائه
بالمائه شفته مسلم مثلي الان اي اختراع او
اي شيء تفاعل بالنسبه للطفل الاصل هو مسلم
بالنسبه لي بمجرد ان تجيب دميه اولا ان اي
طفل
يستفيد منها حتى اعجبوا احنا لما نجيب
روبوت ويكون فاعلا وممثلي بنفس الوقت يمكن
ان يكون الا بالمحبه الى المفضله
كما يحكي مستخدم بس في عندي احمد من مدى
وانتوا التكنولوجيات الحديثه
اصحاب الحاجات الخاصه
هذا الحل
نعم
ان شاء الله انا الحمد لله انه عندي
[موسيقى]
يعني جو ايجابي
كبير
بالابتسامات
جمله واحده اخيره جمله اخيره صوتكم لمن لا
صوت له شكرا
[موسيقى]
اعضاء مجموعه التقييم الجديده كانت اذ
انهم صاغيه لمحمد استمعوا الى براهينه
والان حان وقت قرارهم
نتيجه الان اصبحت جاهزه وسنعرف ان كان سيد
سيد الاسواق من مجموعه التقييم محمد
الجفيري ما حصل على
سته واربعين فاصله تسعه
القرار الحاصل محمد ولبقيه المبدعين سيكون
بعد تصويت لجنه التحكيم النتائج كانت صدمه
بالنسبه اليه ولانه
ترتيب وكيف
يعني على نفسها واحده بين الاول الثاني
يعني انه قديش كانت منافسه شرسه وقديش كل
واحد عم ليش وانا متحمس كثيرا عرف فعلا
النتيجه لانه كل ياتون سواسيه كليتهم
كانوا جاهزين وعم يستهدفوا مارك جدا كبير
وفي انت بالنسبه لك بانوار بعد خروج
العلوم ان هناك من قدم لا نور اه الدعم
سواء من جهه الحكوميه من جهات اه مدنيه من
شركات على سبيل المثال هلا بكل فخر بقول
شركه مدى واحده من الشركات المهمه جدا
اللي عندنا بين بين الشراكه واشتروا من
عندنا شيء مائه وخمسين قطعه ان شاء الله
والحمد لله هلا القطع والمنتج عم يستخدم
في دوله قطر وعم بيساعد فئه كثير كبيره من
الناس اللي عندهم مشاكل سمعيه والحمد لله
انا اعتبر حاليا المنتج الاول اللي بدعم
اللغه العربيه لان بالوطن العربي ما عندك
اي اساس تكنولوجيا تكنولوجيا مساعده
التقدير الله ان شاء الله في
اللحظات الاخيره حتكون فعلا صعبه بمعنى
الكلمه المبدعون على نار الانتظار ومتابعه
نجوم العلوم اكيد ايضا يريدون معرفه من
سيتاهل الى نهائي الموسم التاسع دائما
اللحظات الجميله يسبقها فاصل قصير تتابعون
فيه عبر موقع البرنامج
تواصل اجتماعي فيس بوك وتويتر اخر اخبارنا
خليكم معنا
[موسيقى]
نعم
حياكم الله من جديد
اسيل ومحمد مصيرهم سيحدد الان مشترك واحد
فقط سيغادر برنامج واثنان فرحه الانتقال
الى المربع الذهبي الاخير
الان امام لجنه التحكيم
الخمسين بالمائه الثانيه
الكامله
اعضاء اللجنه
[موسيقى]
شكرا ل اعضاء لجنه التحكيم
مشعل والسيد محمد شكرا جزيلا لكم على كل
ما بذلته خلال الفتره الماضيه الان اعضاء
لجنه التحكيم صوتوا لك وجمعت العلامه
الاولى على العلامه الثانيه
مقعد واحد للاسف
من مربع كم واثنين راح ينتقلون الى المربع
الذهبي
واذكركم المرحله النهائيه الكل الفائز
فيها مبالغ ماديه وايضا
تتويج ومن اربع فائزين في هجوم العلوم
الذي حصل على المركز الثاني برصيد اثنين
وثمانين فاصله واحد هو
مشعل من السعوديه
[تصفيق]
تلك على الطريق الصحيح وصلت الى المركز
الثاني حجز لك ما قاعد فيه الحمد لله
النهايه كل التوفيق الان بين وسيم ومحمد
وسيم شراكه المانيا وجيت الدوحه فتره
قصيره محمد تركت بناتك الهنوف والعنود
موجود معنا اليوم في السجون العلوم اللي
حصل على المركز الاول برصيد ثلاثه فاصله
خمسه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الى هذه المرحله ايضا يعتبر فوز لنا ان
شاء الله كل التوفيق خارج اسوار برنامج
نجوم العلوم موعدنا تجاه الاشاره الاسبوع
المقبل مع التجربه نفسها الجزء الثاني
والاخير من تصفيات مرحله تقييم الاسواق
متابعتنا عبر
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي فيس بوك استقرام
اما الان استودعكم الله مثلما على ال ود
دائما
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ام
[تصفيق]
محمد
وعلى القاده مرحله
من البرنامج هو بدايه لمشوار احسن كثيرا
عن جزء من مشروعه
وكان طريق
العلاقات
[موسيقى]
انا ما اكد انه بيوم كل واحد منها
يخبر
الثانيه تايمز
اجمعنا انت موجود في المجموعه
يكون مثلا يضرب به ان شاء الله يكون اه
الشباب ان شاء الله هذا الدعم او المدرسه
ومدرسه
الكثير